be the change you want to see in the
world
[Music]
there are no shortcuts to any place
worth going
[Music]
you can never cross the ocean until you
have the courage to lose sight of the
shore
[Music]
the greatest danger for most of us is
not that our aim is too high and we miss
it but that our aim is too low when we
hit it
always bear in mind that your own
resolution to succeed is more important
than any other
[Music]
it does not matter how slowly you go as
long as you do not stop
[Music]
you are not a drop in the ocean
you are the entire ocean in a drop
being alone is better than being with
someone bad
do not feel lonely the entire universe
is inside you
lovers don't finally meet somewhere
they're in each other all along
a mother's heart is a child's school
[Music]
the richest person is not the one who
has the most
but the one who needs the least
the mouth should have three gatekeepers
is it true
is it kind
is it necessary
get together like brothers but work
together like strangers
we have one mouth and two ears for a
reason we need to listen more than we
speak
examine what is said
not he who speaks
[Music]
jealousy is nothing more than a fear of
abandonment
a secret is like a dove
when it leaves my hand it takes wings
whatever is forbidden is desired
[Music]
when it comes to the stomach the mind is
lost
a paradise without people is not worth
stepping foot in
[Music]
whoever gets burned by soup blows on
yogurt
wishing does not make a poor man rich
[Music]
a sense of humor is the pull that adds
balance to our steps as we walk the
tightrope of life
you reap what you sow
ask your purse what you should buy
[Music]
you will know your friend in time of
need
a house divided cannot stand
believe what you see and lay aside what
you hear
avoid things that will require an
apology
[Music]
a known mistake is better than an
unknown truth
beware of him to whom you have been
charitable
a pebble can support a barrel
[Music]
beware the level-headed person
if he's angry
[Music]
close the door that brings in the wind
and relax
determination is the key to everything
a tree begins with a seed
be patient and you'll get what you want
[Music]
actions speak louder than words
be wary around your enemy once and your
friend a thousand times a
double-crossing friend knows more about
what harms you
the saddest person is an envious person
distance equals disaffection
anger begins with madness but ends in
regret
[Music]
do not delay today's work for tomorrow
[Music]
arrogance diminishes wisdom
discipline your son when he's young
and be his friend when he's grown
[Music]
arrogance is a weed that grows mostly on
a dunghill
experimentation is the greatest science
[Music]
ask the experienced rather than the
learned
every sun has to set
[Music]
avoid the company of liars but if you
can't don't believe them
do not eat your bread on somebody else's
table
[Music]
if you are charitable you are rich
go with the lesser of two evils
[Music]
if you have an opinion
you better be determined
[Music]
if the wind blows ride it
[Music]
everyone is critical of the flaws of
others but blind to their own
if you're unable to reward then make
sure to thank
falseness lasts an hour
the truth lasts forever
in haste there is regret but in patience
and care there is peace and safety
[Music]
give your friends your money and your
blood
but don't justify yourself
your enemies won't believe it and your
friends won't need it
he who digs a pit for his brother falls
into it
it's better to fix what you have
than wait to get what you don't have
[Music]
forgetting is the plague of knowledge
[Music]
he whose house is made of glass should
not throw stones
if speaking is of silver then silence is
of gold
opinion comes before bravery
planning is half of living
[Music]
the smarter you are the less you speak
[Music]
good health is a crown worn by the
healthy that only the ill can see
[Music]
the best answer comes from the person
who is not angry
the rope of lies is short
the wisest person is the one who can
forgive
[Music]
it's better to avoid mistakes altogether
than to do something you need to
apologize for later
keeping a secret is a commitment
the fruit of silence is tranquility
[Music]
put distance between you and everything
dirty
lack of intelligence is the greatest
poverty
the monkey is a gazelle in the eyes of
its mother
the house of a tyrant is a
ruin laugh and the whole world laughs
with you
cry and you cry alone
lying is a disease
truth is the cure
[Music]
necessity is the mother of invention
one will not attain everything he wishes
for
the winds blow where they will
not where the ships wish
[Music]
silence is the sign of approval
[Music]
speaking is not seeing
[Music]
the world is like a belly dancer it
dances a little while for everyone
think of your exit before you enter
tomorrow is close if you have patience
visit rarely and you will be loved more
wealth comes like a turtle and leaves
like a gazelle
[Music]
a foolish man may be known by six things
anger without cause speech without
profit
change without progress
inquiry without object
trusting a stranger
and mistaking foes for friends
so
[Music]
you